[Musik]
und jetzt das heute
journal schön guten
Abend Verzeihung seit 78 Tagen herrscht
Krieg in N Ost seit 78 Tagen
entschuldigung ich habe ein Frosch im
Hals und muss tatsächlich kurz was
trinken das bei der letzten Sendung vor
Weihnachten so Verzeihung fangen wir
noch mal von vorne an
also seit 78 Tagen herrscht Krieg in N
Ost seit 78 Tagen trauern in Israel
Menschen um die Opfer des 7 Oktober
gleichzeitig hoffen sie weiterhin auf
die Freilassung der Geiseln die sich
noch in den Händen der Hammers befinden
seit 78 Tagen ist aber auch die Welt der
Palästinenser eine andere auch sie
trauern um Opfer die es tagtäglich zu
beklagen gibt gleichzeitig müssen sie
zusehen dass sie irgendwo und irgendwie
überleben die Hoffnung auf einen
Waffenstillstand können sie dagegen erst
einmal begraben die Angriffe der
israelischen Armee gehen im Norden wie
im Süden und vermindert weiter und zwar
so lange bis alle Geiseln freigelassen
sind und die Hamas im Gazastreifen
eliminiert ist betonte der israelische
Außenminister da heute erneut ein
humanitärer Waffenstillstand hatte es
gestern auf Druck der USA nicht in die
neueste und verbindliche
UN-Resolution
geschafft dafür soll es nun vermehrt
humanitäre Hilfe geben Susanna Santina
in Tel Aviv schönen guten Abend und
diese humanitäre Hilfe soll rasch
schnell und durch die UNO koordiniert
werden aber wie soll das gehen wenn
Israel ununterbrochen und massiv
angreift ja genau das ist das Problem
dun ja es finden ja fast täglich
Luftangriffe statt und natürlich ist es
dann schwierig große Ladungen von
Hilfsgütern ins Land zu lassen und dann
auch zu verteilen und deswegen wächst ja
auch der Druck auf premier netanyah eben
über eine Waffenruhe zu verhandeln aber
man muss wirklich sagen das Problem
liegt nicht hauptsächlich bei Netanyahu
in diesem Punkt sondern bei der Hamas
den die sagt wir wollen gar nicht über
eine Waffenruhe verhandeln wir wollen
ein Ende des Krieges und erst dann sind
wir vielleicht bereit über die
Freilassung der Geiseln zu verhandeln
mhm 1,9 der 2,4 Millionen Palästinenser
im Gazastreifen sollen ja mittlerweile
Binnenflüchtlinge sein wo im
Gazastreifen ist denn der Schutz von
Zivilisten überhaupt noch
gewährleistet also es gibt tatsächlich
einen kleinen Bereich ein kleines Gebiet
in der Nähe der ägyptischen Grenze im
Süden Gazas da sagt die Armee man werde
es nicht bombardieren geflüchtete
könnten dorthingehen aber natürlich ist
der Platz begrenzt und du hast es ja
gesagt es gibt rund 1,9 Millionen
Binnenflüchtlinge und eigentlich sind
die nirgends in Gaza mittlerweile sicher
weder im Norden noch im Süden wir sehen
ja auch immer wie das wieder das zivile
Gebäude angegriffen werden da sagt die
Armee eben dass man immer wieder auch
Terroristen hamasterroristen dort findet
und ihre Strukturen und dass man
deswegen auch zivile Opfer nicht immer
vermeiden könne Susanna Santina mit
ihren Einschätzungen aus Tel Aviv vielen
Dank
traumatisch sind die Erlebnisse allemal
für Kinder wie für Erwachsene dieser
Zustand trifft aber auch auf Israel zu
auf das gesamte Land denn fast jeder
dort kennt jemanden der am 7 oktober von
der Terrorgruppe Hamas ermordet wurde
oder entführt oder vergewaltigt oder
anderweitig misshandelt das Land und die
Menschen sie werden nie mehr so sein wie
es mal war das hat unsere Reporterin
Henriette dem mer im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes
gesehen Wiedersehen beim Klassentreffen
eine ehemalige Schulklasse die für das
Schicksal vieler Menschen in Israel
steht tote verschleppte nach dem 7
Oktober 2023 und dem Überfall der
radikalislamischen Hamas ist nichts mehr
wie es einmal
war wir wollen einfach nur noch einmal
alle zusammen sein die Gefühle die wir
jetzt Teilen jeder hier wir haben alle
einiges durchgemacht wir sind durch die
Hölle
gegangen es gibt ein Video das Jahrgangs
2003 es zeigt das Jahrbuch der Schule
malale habsor nahe des Gazastreifens auf
dem Klassenfoto am Rand wie immer die
Lehrerin rotem Calderon sie wurde am 7
oktober im kibutzberie von der Hamas
erschossen ich hab das ein Art Nebel
versunken und so kann ich mich gar nicht
richtig fühlen ich weiß gar nicht was
los ist alles ist anders mein Blick auf
die Menschen hat sich
geändert 20 Jahre nach ihrem
Schulabschluss treffen sie sich sie
lachen über die Fotos erzählen was
inzwischen passiert ist und beklagen
ihre Toten und
Vermissten drei Männer aus dem Jahrgang
sind in den Händen der Hamas Tamir mit
dem großen Lachen der damals träumte in
Jamaika zu sein ist jetzt in Gaza
genauso
wie it der so sensibel ist wurde
verschleppt nachdem seine Eltern beide
ermordet
wurden wir haben unseren ersten Kuchen
zusammebacken und ruinierten den
Backofen und ich sehe immer noch die
Reaktion seiner Mutter was wir an diesem
Tag in Ihrer Küche angerichtet
haben ST imutzraum vor der ham Eltern
und Großeltern wurden ermordet nicht nur
familienstarben auch jar
Hund wir werden lernen müssen mit dieser
Trauer zu leben und gleichzeitig ist es
so ein unglaubliches Gefühl Leben in
diese Welt zu bringen einerseits dieses
Glück und gleichzeitig ist alles in so
dunkle Farben getaucht manchmal habe ich
Schuldgefühle weil ich so glücklich
bin
die Klasse wie ein Brennglas Israels
eigentlich alle hier sind betroffen von
Angst und
Trauer trotz des Bemühens das Paradies
auf Erden aufzubauen zeige die Realität
des Lebens dass das Böse existiert und
dass uns vor ihm weder eine Institution
noch ein Gesetz schützt Worte die auf
viele Ereignisse passen gefunden hat sie
heute der Prager Erzbischof anl des
trauergottesdiensts für die Opfer des
Amoklaufs vor zi Tagen 14 Menschen
tötete der Attentäter an der Fakultät 14
Rosen lagen daher auf dem Altar über
Gottesdienst und Staatstrauer Oliver
Flamm wie schwer muss es sein an ihre
getöteten Freunde
komelitonen Angehörigen zu denken ein
Blick in ihre Gesichter sagt alles in
diesem kaum zu ertragenden Moment in dem
die Stadt ein ganzes Land Inn
hält am Trauergottesdienst im feitdom
Nehmen auch viele Studentinnen und
Studenten
[Musik]
Teil wenn jemand sein Leben so
unnötigerweise verliert so die Rektorin
der Universität dann dauert es sehr
lange das zu akzeptieren gerade ein
junger Mensch hätte noch so viele
Gelegenheiten gehabt anderen etwas Gutes
zu tun darum trifft uns das noch
härter
noch immer wird nach dem Motiv des
24-Jährigen Täters gesucht die Polizei
fand bei ihm weitere Waffen nur ihr
schnelles Eingreifen habe noch
Schlimmeres verhindert so die Regierung
die Tatwaffe hatte der Mann legal
gekauft eine Verschärfung der
Waffengesetze lehnte die tschechische
Regierung wie die meisten EU-Länder seit
Jahren ab bis heute können viele das
Geschehene kaum
verarbeiten unsere Nachbarin ist hier
gestorben sie war Professorin an der Uni
musikprofessorin das was hier passiert
ist Bericht mir das Herz es ist kaum zu
glauben mindestens vier Menschen wurden
inzwischen festgenommen weil sie die
Bluttat öffentlich gelobt oder ähnliche
Taten angekündigt hatten die Polizei hat
ihre Präsenz deshalb bis auf weiteres
deutlich
verstärkt und die Nachrichten beginnen
jetzt mit dem Krieg in nar Ost bzw mit
den Auswirkungen die dieser Krieg mit
sich bringt Z be auf die internationale
Schiffahrt da drohen die iranischen
Revolutionsgarden mit weiteren
seeblockaden bald könne es auch das
Mittelmeer treffen so ein hochrangiger
general bisher hat Iran eine
Verstrickung in schiffsattacken durch
jemenitische Hus Rebellen geleugnet
dagegen heißt es aus den USA
Geheimdienstinformationen würden genau
das belegen unterdessen meldeten
britische Behörden einen drohenangriff
auf ein Schiff im Indischen Ozean der
Frachter soll mit Israel in Verbindung
stehen und beschä worden
sein der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung klein hat sich besorgt
über die Sicherheitslage von Juden in
Deutschland geäußert seit dem Holocaust
seien sie nicht mehr in so großer Gefahr
gewesen sagte er den funkezeitungen seit
dem hamasangriff auf Israel am 7 Oktober
zählte das Bundeskriminalamt mehr als
1000 Straftaten mit antisemitischem
Hintergrund das berichtet die Welt am
Sonntag die Polizei hat die
sicherheitsmaßen Namen am Kölner Dom
massiv verschärft es gebe einen
Gefahrenhinweis für Silvester man leite
aber schon jetzt alles für die
Sicherheit der Besucher ein Einzelheiten
wurden nicht genannt die Deutsche
Presseagentur und die Bildzeitung
sprechen von Anschlagsplänen von
Islamisten auch in anderen europäischen
Städten laut BILD gab es erste
Festnahmen der Staatsschutz hat die
Ermittlungen
übernommen Familien mit geringem
Einkommen erhalten im neuen Jahr einen
höheren Kinderzuschlag
Familienministerin Paus sagte der
Augsburger Allgemeinen die Leistung
steige pro Monat und Kind von
250 auf bis zu 292 € damit erhöhe sich
der Zuschlag stärker als ursprünglich
geplant hunderte lebensmitteltafeln
können den zunehmenden Andrang nicht
mehr bewältigen ein Drittel der Tafeln
in Deutschland habe inzwischen
Wartelisten oder sogar temporäre
aufnahmestops das sagte der Vorsitzende
stepph dem redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland im Vergleich zu den
Vorjahren zähle man 50% mehr Kunden
insgesamt bis zu 2 Millionen
gleichzeitig gebe es weniger
Lebensmittelspenden schauen wir noch
kurz aufs herausfordernde Wetter da warn
der Deutsche Wetterdienst vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen in einigen Mittelgebirgen und
vor starkem Tauwetter im Erzgebirge
überhaupt wird es wohl ein
Weihnachtswetter zum drinnen bleiben
denn an Heiligabend regnet es zeitweise
in vor pmann anfangs mit Schnee dabei
weht ein starker Wind an den Küsten und
auf den Bergen mit sturmböhen das ganze
bei 7 bis
13° auch die folgenden Tage werden
unbeständig mit viel Wind und zeitweise
Regen am ehesten zeigt sich die Sonne
südlich der Donau dabei wird es etwas
kühler und noch die Lottozahlen 1 4 8 12
17 22 Superzahl ist die Z weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden Sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
556 zum Schluss dieser Sendung und so
kurz vor Heiligabend und jetzt auch
wieder ohne Frosch im Hals soll es auch
hier ein bisschen weihnachtlich werden
und wie geht das besser als mit dem
Blick auf einen Weihnachtsmarkt
inklusive weihnachtlicher festb beides
hat in Dresen Tradition und die wollen
sich die Menschen trotz schlechtem
Wetter und gestiegener Preise nicht
nehmen lassen Cornelia
schimens Dresden startet am Abend in die
Weihnachtsfeiertage mit der
traditionellen Open Air fesper vor der
Frauenkirche gemeinsames Beten
innerhalten zur Ruhe kommen Ruhe am Ende
eines Jahres das für viele nicht leicht
war die Händler auf dem weltberühmten
Striezelmarkt sind trotzdem überwiegend
zufrieden wir hatten am Anfang sehr sehr
gute Umsätze gemacht jetzt wo es ein
bisschen regnet ist es ein bisschen
schwierig weil auch die Kunden etwas
weniger kommen logischerweise aber
grundsätzlich ja es hält sich noch auf
dem guten Niveau Pyramiden ab 300 €
aufwärts Räuchermännchen für 100
Hersteller und Händler müssen die
gestiegenen Kosten für Personal Energie
und Rohstoffe auf die Kunden umlegen
gekauft wurde dieses Jahr trotzdem wenn
auch verhaltener Leute gucken ganz genau
drauf was kostet ein Artikel aber der
Vorteil ist dass wir im Erzgebirge
ausschließlich Qualitätsware herstellen
und die Kunden aus aller Welt wissen
dass Erzgebirge was ganz Besonderes ist
dass das nicht zum Schnäppchenpreis zu
bekommen ist sondern dass dort wirklich
ganz viel Handwerk drinne steckt und
sein Preis wert ist und damit kaufen
auch Weihnachten spielt das keine Rolle
da wird das Jahr gesparen ist nur das
Wetter jetzt freute nicht so im
tagelangen Dauerregen schließt der
589 Striezelmarkt die verst ziehen eine
positive Bilanz mehr als 2 Millionen
Besucher kamen aus dem Inn und Ausland
der alljährliche Verkaufsschlager
Glühwein die Tasse für 4 €
Leute die Leute
jetzten
eng
vi
Mert ein oder zwe gehen und dann
schon ja
weihnachtenegal ja das eine Mal auf dem
Weihnachtsmark kann man noch mal richtig
drafen und seien die Krisen in diesem
Jahr auch noch so groß sie sollen es
möglichst nicht spüren die Kinder das
Geld sit bei weiten nicht mehr so locker
aber hier darf ich die Kinder natürlich
nicht wissen lassen wie es mir
persönlich geht ich muss hier eine
Illusion erzeugen und wenn ich die
Kinder sehe und die Kinderaugen wirklich
da bin ich sogar geneigt jeden tar
doppelt
auszugeben na dann fröhliche Weihnachten
aus
Dresden und beim Blick in die Welt sind
die kommenden Weihnachtstage vielleicht
ja auch eine gute Gelegenheit um inne zu
halten zu überlegen was wirklich wichtig
ist und auch an die zu denken denen es
nicht so gut geht wir hier also das
gesamte Team vor und hinter der Kamera
wünschen Ihnen jedenfalls ein frohes ein
gesegnetes und vor allen Dingen auch ein
besinnliches Weihnachtsfest mit lieben
Menschen und hoffentlich nur guten
Nachrichten feiern sie schön machen sie
es gut wo auch immer sie sind
[Musik]
tschüss so jetzt
geht's